you
the Nobel assembly at Karolinska
Institute has today decided to award the
Nobel Prize in Physiology or medicine
2012 jointly to John B Gurdon and Shinya
Yamanaka for the discovery that mature
cells can be reprogrammed to become
pluripotent the Nobel for sampling
uncover lynskey instituted a toy to be
Slauson a Nobel Prize for Physiology
automated seen this llaves slide house
itself reminds them and john b garden
Shinya Yamanaka children back home the
UN Human Rights Ellen include patents
souvenir now assembly Nobel de
l'institut olinska a disease issue that
will be a queen Bell the physiology of
the medicine to Madhu's concerned more
John P Gurdon Shinya Yamanaka public
uber the possibility of a proclamation
the Selena doll on salute Lou Caputo no
vilensky assembly Africa rulings come
Institute referee lasagna Pradesh new
beletsky premium for physiology
eliminate Zener revenue John Dee Gordon
Shinya Yamanaka so creative area program
Mira Vanya's really clear to the jury
patent here thank you and with that I
would like to ask professor Tomas
Perelman of the Nobel Committee to
present the science behind the prize
good morning this year's Nobel Prize
Awards the discovery that has changed
the way we understand how cells in the
body becomes specialized and it has
provided entirely new tools for
effective development of drugs and new
therapies on this first picture we see a
fertilized egg that develops first in
turn embryo and then lean into an adult
human with all its specialized cells
such as muscles nerves and skin as we
all know this process always moves in
the same direction from immature cells
in the embryo to specialized cells in
the adult a common metaphor for this
process visualizes how cells move
downhill in a landscape to finally reach
their destinations as specialized mature
cells at the bottom of deep valleys
scientists believed for a long time
that our genes are likely altered in
this process in ways so that this
journey could never be set in Reverse
and it seemed impossible for mature
cells to travel back all the way to the
immature state at the top of the
mountain
now John Gurdon changed this view by a
groundbreaking experiment in frog cells
he thought that if genes contrary to the
common view were intact in mature cells
its nucleus should be able to develop
when moved into the cellular context of
an egg so he destroyed the nucleus of an
egg and used a fine pipette to transfer
and replace it with the nucleus from a
mature intestinal cell from a tadpole in
most cases this modified egg could not
develop but in a few cases it developed
into normal
swimming tadpoles and later add up frogs
at first many were skeptical I'm
surprised about this result
but this paradigm-shifting discovery was
confirmed and we now know that the same
experience works to clone mammals
the first being Dolly the sheep but
later also mice Carroll's pigs and other
animals Gordon had shown that the
nucleus of a mature cell retains all
genetic information that is required to
generate an animal but could this also
be done in intact cells without
dissecting out the cell nucleus and
using a pipette that like Gordon did and
placing it in an egg
Shinya Yamanaka over 40 years later made
the discovery that also whole intact
mature cells can be reprogrammed and
that this could be achieved by a
surprisingly simple procedure
now Yamanaka he studied genes that are
important for the function of resultant
stem cells clear potent stem cells are
found in the early embryo and can
develop into all different types of
mature cells in the body and he thought
that some stem cell genes may induce
pluripotency if they would be
transferred into mature cells in the
mouse 24 candidates stem cell genes were
selected his target cell was a skin cell
from a mouse now usually scientists
transfer genes into other cells one by
one but in a strikingly bold experiment
all of these 2040s were introduced in
one single step into the skin cells and
a few cells became reprogram into cells
that could generate all the mature cells
in in in a mouse they had now become
pluripotent further experiments
demonstrated that only four genes were
needed for this induction of you
potency he named these cells induced
pluripotent stem cells or iPS cells the
i-pass
cell technique is the truly
groundbreaking discovery that has opened
a whole new research area in cell
biology and medicine for example IPS
cells can now be generated from patients
with disease and from these IPS cells
mature cells can be cultured so that we
now have a procedure that gives access
to new cell models for disorders that
previously have been very difficult to
study this is a final picture that
summarizes the fundamental discovery
made by this year's laureates and
illustrates how John Gurdon and Shinya
Yamanaka reinstated through potency by
either nuclear transfer in 1962 or by
gene transfer in 2006 thanks to these
two scientists we now know that
development is not strictly a one-way
street here finally we have the two
laureates to the left John Gordon from
Great Britain who is a professor at the
University of Cambridge and the Gordon
Institute to the right Shinya Yamanaka
born in Japan and a professor at Kyoto
University thank you
you